[Music]
he became a developer because he loved
games you always wanted to take them
beyond what we know to create truly
innovative and interesting experiences
you had an idea which you had the
courage to turn into reality
you learned skills you didn't have you
constantly learn and adapt and make
decisions every single day you think
you're prepared then you realize there's
always something new to learn it's risky
and scary and at the same time
exhilarating the freedom to create the
collaboration with other like-minded
people the sleepless nights the coffee's
the looks of your family and friends the
leaps of faith the pride in what you do
there are ups the first drawing the
first time you make something move using
code the moment you get it out to the
world the reaction of the first person
who tries it out that's what it's all
about
there are many downs you mess up on the
way but you don't give up when you fail
you learn you continue with passion
creativity pushing yourself forward and
the next day comes
you
[Music]